welcome back to grandma unfiltered
posted by me josh smith
and today we are joined by the four
queens
of pop music it's little mix
how are we doing we
are as good as can be we're very happy
to be back together
this has been the longest we've been
apart how's that been for you being
apart for that long
what have you missed the most about each
other
do you know what just laughing every day
and like just
gossiping and talking about all the
silly things that we talk about
obviously we're always performing seeing
our fans and just
being and i think as well you guys are
always using your platform for the
greater good
constantly all the time team up with
simple again
to for this amazing campaign surrounded
by ditch the label with that amazing
charity as well
do you think that given the context of
win right now
we need kindness more than ever before
i just think you know giving a
compliment to someone
um you never know what someone is going
through and i think to be kind and give
someone a compliment can just completely
change their day and their mindset
can you imagine how amazing this world
would be
everyone was just nice everyone was kind
to each other
it'd kindness also starts within doesn't
it about being kind
to yourself and kind to others
is there a time that you wish you were
kinder for yourself
quite recently unfortunately i haven't
been very kind to myself
and i think it's because i've been stuck
indoors for a few months
of literally quite a few bottles of wine
thank you modest
yes
not let myself go but i think there was
a period where like obviously we all
found out we have been locked down and
say oh sweet time
so i punished myself for a while about
that
so i had to learn to instead of being
really angry
myself just fighting in myself and not
being very kind to myself but the way i
looked and felt
i had to learn to be like you know what
yeah give yourself a break you've had a
bit of time off
you know everyone's going through it
right now mentally
and let's find a different way to
support them with this i think you know
what i'm going to be honest
and say the times i actually like
pick myself apart and feel miserable is
when i get packed
in a bikini all packed
in a way that when i'm not aware that
i'm being packed
and two it makes me feel dirty do you
get that
he would be like oh you look great and
i'm like are you kidding me do i look
like that
and then i'll cry like i'll actually cry
and i'll be like oh
yeah and it really gets to me
and i have to remind myself that and
then i have to learn to just be like
let it go it's a few bad pictures who
cares
like yeah yeah but it takes a lot to get
that
yeah it's really horrible you know i
mean i went through
a period of just not thinking i was good
enough
um and i wish i wasn't so hard on myself
like picked myself apart
for my ability and i wish i just
believed in it more because it's always
been there
but from losing confidence i just
just blamed it on just thinking oh
you need to improve on that you need to
do this you need to see more of this
like when really
i was fine the way i was so i wish i
kind of just
told myself that and didn't let it
fester oh i could be kind to myself
every day
myself most days and if i'm feeling good
in myself then i'll praise myself
like jade if i'm feeling in myself and i
just really
beat myself up about it and i've
literally picked myself apart
and then sometimes i have to check
myself enough to be like it's life
sometimes you're gonna like yeah
sometimes
you're gonna eat crap food and you're
gonna put away and that's just
life and sometimes you're gonna lose it
and you're gonna
stop cleaning yourself because you would
never do that to someone else
like i genuinely believe that we find it
so easy to be so
nasty to ourselves but yet we never do
that to someone else and things that we
say to ourselves
we would never project that on anyone
else and i think it's so easy to do that
and it's so easy to like
you know oh god i'm not discussing and
just saying these hopeful things
and we don't actually realize what we
what we're doing to ourselves mentally
when really to train our brain to like
saying positive things
i generally think
that we all have to go on but i
generally think that if we can be kinder
to ourselves and say more positive
things to ourselves than negative
we'd all just
ourselves for sure we need to be our own
best friends right
that's what you need yeah the
relationship that you have with yourself
is
the hardest yeah i mean i was talking
about allyship
to you the other day jade when we were
talking about that how important is to
be allies to each other
given that what has happened recently is
that
taking on a whole new meaning to you as
well yeah
i think now more than ever um
yeah allyship is is everything you know
change doesn't happen unless you have
allies
there are so many issues that are
finally
being taught about and something is
finally being done
i feel like now more never election is
key
to change and it's all about using your
voice right the greater good you guys
always do that how has that changed
as you've gone through your career the
power of your own voice and how you've
used it i think we've always used our
platform
and in positive ways but i feel like
more recently we've maybe gained more
confidence
in being able to speak up on issues and
i think that's one
due to just growing up and maturing and
having the confidence to do so i think
it's also
being more educated enough to speak up
about things
so i think there's also a bit of a fear
when you have such a huge
form of doing saying the right things
all the time
oh my god for sure and throughout this
whole thing no matter what you guys have
been through you've
had each other haven't you an amazing
sisterhood
what and the relationship you've
had before taught you about the power of
sisterhood
it's everything the power that we
hold like as for women i think is just
so
incredibly strong and just amazing and
yeah i think it's good it just goes to
show that when there's more of you that
stand for something like change can
happen and like it does make people
listen more
and so yeah i'm proud of us for like
like what joey said like using our
platform
that was a huge platform so we didn't do
anything with it and didn't speak about
what we believe in the standoff
for what we believe in then i don't
really feel like we'd be
serving our purpose as a girl band what
do you think each of you
helped you through the most personally
there's been a time you've been like
you've leaned into that power of that
system
for each of you individually what's that
been like perry what's that been like
for you
the best thing about us guys is like
we're there for each other emotionally
and it's like we go through the ride
together yeah i think when one of us is
like kind of hurt and we kind of
work with them we're just there we're
like shoulders to cry on
back in the end we go like give each
other advice like we have each other's
backs it looks like that constant
support system of like having sisters
there all the time yeah i think that's
what i love
about us like we always always have each
other's backs so
it's just important i think the industry
we're in the things that happen like we
go through it together and that's why
it's like less daunting
yes yes and what's that been like for
you jesse what's
the girl group helped you through the
most we're a good energy to be around
and
like when someone is feeling down we'll
never will never ever leave them to like
just be down like always trying to lift
each other's spirits and make each other
feel good and like
just in general i just think that people
we always just try to make other people
feel good and each other feel good like
with confidence whether
there's so much pressure to act a
certain way look a certain way
say the right thing and i think knowing
that we have that sort of support for
each other
when i was during a lockdown like not
seeing the girls
i felt like there was so much going on
and
i felt like i was dealing with it all on
my own because i wasn't with them yeah
do you know what i mean as soon as i
went back together it's us against the
world you know what i mean like
and it felt so weird being on my own
because we've never had to do that
before so
i think that's what's so special about
you guys because you are such a positive
force
for change and for good but
unfortunately there's a lot of
negativity that's still around
and one in three people still experience
cyber bullying which is
crazy and that's what dictionary would
talk about i know obviously jesse you
spoke
a lot about this and very passionately
openly about it but
how do you guys feel negativity now when
you come up again
is it sort of a difficult thing or is it
it becomes easier but does it still
affect you and how's it
going i think um i mean we're all human
like obviously we're going to have days
when certain things do affect us but i
definitely think we're a lot stronger
now
but we've got a thicker skin like
i don't think things that would have
bothered us back then would bother us
now if we see them because we are just
we just got big skin like
it doesn't really pop for us as much
anymore which yeah and then i kind of
feel like i'm a bit
immune to it now we're just starting
also we're very confident in ourselves
now
but you know we we're all human we're
not robots and sometimes certain things
do affect us but
we love being in a group and if we are
down we lift each other up
yes
speaking of ditch the label that concept
in itself do you feel like you
personally have had to like let go of a
certain label
or have a label thrust upon you that
you've had to then be like
ask abayana i need to fight against that
and release that from me
i feel like the term role model
and is
lovely but it's also
it's also quite um terrifying yeah it's
quite
scary i'm still a human and i'm not
gonna
get it right all the time so please let
me
still what i learn and it has put a bit
of pressure on us over the years
of um you know having to
to be that when we are just for
normal women who are just trying to live
our lives unless that's
lovely and people look up to us that's
amazing but at the same time
you know you know i feel like the
pressure yeah yeah
even like scrutiny what we wear on stage
like if we where we're saying
like we're wearing that to move and to
feel comfortable
and also yeah exactly because it makes
me feel empowered it makes me feel
sexy but this is the problem like why
are we why do we get something
all the time literally dressing our age
do we leave well with all rather there's
so many solo
eyes that we're leotards and as soon as
they were they're living like
it's just mad but is that because
of who we are like little mix and like
having a younger fan base like is that
why people
don't do that and
we are women and we we want to embrace
i wonder why we get scrutinized all the
time for what we wear
like when we're on tour and we don't
stop like when we're onto our weekend
it's constant isn't start to finish we
don't stop dancing we don't stop jumping
around
because our main goal for people coming
to alumni sponsor is we pop on
a show like the whole we could easily
dress
in gowns we could easily wear track
suits from top to bottom
but that's not what we're about like
we're putting on a huge sword
sure we want to be comfortable so if you
want to come to a little mix concert and
see it's fully clawed we ain't going to
move
so you either have that you don't does
that make sense but it's got i think
it's just goes back to the
point of being women i think it just
gets scrutinized for everything
yes you breathe
it's also just like we need to stop a
society judging people what makes other
people feel empowered like
if you feel empowered wearing a leotard
wear it like who's
why can't they're not people for any of
those kind of decisions
exactly i honestly believe though that
when people are just negative
towards you it's a projection of how
they actually feel about themselves
yeah someone's judgment on you is is
really their insecurity talking
yeah 100 percent on them you know
how they're feeling it's only negative
people that feel
don't feel good in themselves are quite
insecure to project that on other people
because it makes them feel better and
one thing i wanted to ask you guys just
to finish off was
if you could put the you on a zoom call
it was just about to go into little bits
what would you want to say to them i
would say prepare yourself
for the
wildest nine years of your life
yeah and i would say don't be
so hard on yourself know
that you're enough as you are
yeah don't doubt who you are your
abilities
and what you're capable of doing i would
say that you're about
to learn a lot about yourself and that's
a good thing
you know everything's a lesson business
so
enjoy the ride well thank you so much
for joining me
i love you guys always spreading that
kindness
always here for that positivity so keep
playing it spreading the positive vibes
because we're all here for
big
it
[Music]